we found evidence for a gravitational
wave background for the very first time
but what is a gravitational wave and
what on Earth is a gravitational wave
background so gravitational waves are
ripples in the fabric of space-time and
if there's a lot of these gravitational
wave signals they can add together and
give you a gravitational wave background
so we believe that supermassive black
hole binary systems are creating this
gravitational wave background so when
galaxies merge their Central
supermassive black holes should also
emerge and when they merge they create
these gravitational wave signals these
are so low frequency that we can detect
them when they have periods of about 30
years or one nanohertz and it takes them
about 25 million years to merge that
means that there's a lot of time for
another galaxy merger to happen and
another one and another one and then
there are so many signals that they
create this gravitational wave
background
so this is really important for us to
understand how the universe works do
galaxies emerge as often as we think
they do looking to the Future we're
hoping to make maps of the gravitational
wave background and to also find
individual merging supermassive black
holes
foreign